hey guys Dennis here the founder thay
here and I'm David your resident comic
book and video game guru and this is our
review of Vikings season one entire
season History Channel History Channel
David lent me the blu-ray I just watched
it I think over the weekend because you
got to watch the show okay my overall
thoughts I like the show it's good it's
good it's not I don't think it's a great
show I think it's a good show I think
it's you know it's fun to watch it's
entertaining I don't think it's very
deep at all no it basically the title
gives you like it's Vikings and you get
Viking that's what you get yeah but I
like it enjoyed you know I'll keep
watching - season 2 what are your
overall thoughts on the show in general
I really like the show I'm a big fan of
Michael Hurst who's the showrunner he
also was a stoner for tutors with
Jonathan Rhys Meyers and that was a good
show tutors with some a lot more soap
opera than this one is this one's kind
of more action-adventure kind of
historic weird historical
interpretations of things I don't I love
the whole thing with you know traveling
we're gonna spoil stuff here so if you
haven't seen season one you're gonna
talk about some things like the whole
traveling to the west and and all that
it's a nice it's kind of a show to watch
in between you know when Game of Thrones
is done and what time you Game of
Thrones comes back it's not I'm not
saying it's at that level yeah but it's
got a good enough cast the settings
interesting you know I think they I
think they also shoot Northern Ireland
as well to mimic Scandinavia and a
little special effects of course added
never I think it's good I really like
the show oh yeah when you mention that
game and when Game of Thrones I had
mentioned that on Twitter like I was
like it's not on the same level no this
guy this guy started arguing with me
saying it was in the level
no it wasn't saying that I shouldn't
have even mentioned it in the same red
well it's not it isn't on the same level
but that's what I was saying and then
also this was a thing that I thought was
odd he said that he thought Vikings was
like a Michael Bay and I was on that's
where I totally disagree Michael hearse
is a better writer well not only that
just it just doesn't have that style
there's not any big explosions or well
not even that just it's not that
over-the-top I think I think because the
person was from I think from Iceland and
you like Viking war and
sure there's a lot of things that are
exaggerated and different from real life
sure but it's not on the level of
Michael Bay Michael Bay is like I
mentioned this Call of Duty if you want
you know play Call of Duty the way that
the first player the the singular
narrative storyline not the
single-player campaign not I'm not
talking about the animal type play
Michael Bay also wasn't introducing in
building he's not in truth he's not
interested in building character Michael
Hurst is trying to develop character
whether it's as deep as Game of Thrones
or not he is exploring characters I mean
especially like I love you know jumping
ahead way to the end I love when Ragnar
takes his son and appleson said that
place we do all the big sacrifices it's
like the sacrifice of the gods and I
mean they're like he does try like you
really see Athelstan coming from a monk
you know and you know Northumbria - you
know Scandinavia and seen this different
culture different gods differ like with
Thor and they talk about milnor and the
a milliner and the hammer and this is a
lot of good character development in the
show the show has alike it's I hope the
season 2 is gonna be bigger and you know
they're really good just heavy
comfortable with what they're doing so
there's a lot of interesting stories to
explore yeah I also hope it's faster
paced I mentioned to you before that I
felt like that they also we talked about
this a lot in some other shows that we
review I felt like there was a set
amount of story and the kinda stretched
it out for writing episodes like I think
the first three episodes could have been
done in two episodes no like by the time
they got to this place or that place
like it was like it just felt like it
took a long time yeah so I hope that the
second season is faster paced and also
maybe even get into more complex they do
have some subplots going on you know
with the brother Rolo and stuff like
that and but it does seem to really just
it's one main storyline right now
because then I was I was impressed with
how History Channel and maybe I
shouldn't be shocked cuz like a Andy's
in the game now you know they have the
Hatfields and McCoys series I did right
and they have Base Motel
Discovery Channel now even has that
like series with the guy actor who
played Robb Stark Richard Madden all
these kind of networks you wouldn't
expect drama to come from like real
serious drama series are now doing these
series but I thought
firk I thought casting they did a good
job I think I think it was smart on a
couple levels one two so again we're
gonna spoil stuff so Gabrielle burns in
the show I like that they kill them but
that was kind of a bold move because
they had they had to have like one solid
actor you'd kind of identify with like
okay that's a good actor yeah Gabrielle
burns a good Irish and we know he's good
but I thought they surrounded him with a
good supporting cast - yeah I saw I
expected the Earl Gabriel Byrne
character to die I didn't think it was
gonna happen season 1 now right yeah
they're gonna happen in season 2 right
so that was something that they did kind
of that wasn't slowed down no no and
then and then Ragnar becoming the Earl
right which we saw coming no I really do
like I like the cast I like it's shot
beautifully oh yeah they look like
Vikings like no-one's it's not no
offense it's not revolution but the
girls like I mean Katheryn Winnick his
wife is she's hot it's hot but at least
she looks a little dirty she got some
gruff she looks like she looks like she
lives in that time for like Game of
Thrones it's not like look at that came
out of a salon or something like which
is just ridiculous you know no III like
it's it's as authentic as it's going to
be in the year 2000 you know I mean you
know look good okay so yeah I mean
overall the production values good I
just you know I just hope that the
second season moves it along a little
faster and maybe creates more subplots
right yeah be curious here what you're
all I know when des and I posted that
we're doing a Vikings I know a lot of
you on Twitter were like oh I've already
watched I like that show or you're like
oh I'm going to watch it if you guys are
watching us let us know what you think I
mean I'm really curious to hear a lot
people think of the set up for season 2
it's like we're gonna start off with a
battle Rollo has you know he's got we
always is always there like that he was
gonna betrayed his brother yeah but he
never did even when he was tempted until
the very end he's like I'm gonna fight
for you this other or all they were
trying to and they've been and that's I
think one of the better parts of this
show because they really show how
jealousy is yeah of his brother and the
other people like the Earl and this new
it's a king of a different Kingdom the
well I think he's in he's another Earl
the one that the king sent him over yeah
he's another Earl
okay in him they can see in Rollo like
that jealousy and they take advantage of
it they use his pride against him and
Rollo's not the brightest no like he
should be smart enough to realize that
he's being used right and that they just
using him to attack his brother but i
but yeah pride got in the way and then
to I'm curious to see what's gonna
happen with Ragnar I mean his uh his
daughters dead he doesn't know he
doesn't know I believe the baby did not
survive and there was a sickness you
know the plague that hit the his town so
and he's cheating and he was cheating
with another girl
so we David now is pregnant so drama
gotta have a love triangle care what
show you gotta have a love triangle so I
make here to see what that's gonna be
like next he's a lot of interesting
things going on I like his relationship
with his son
- yeah the son was upset because he was
there who knows been recast as you told
me he well I think probably because
maybe he's gonna be older no I don't
know I wonder how well they're gonna
jump right I don't know how what the
time jumping right yeah but who knows I
did like that how his son was a you know
upset with his father sleeping with
another man any it's almost interesting
because I guess in that culture it's
like they kind of know that that when
the men go off they're gonna cheat
they're gonna cheat you know that was
like because there are the earliest
conversations in in the first episode
cuz even that guy talked to him you know
one of the Ragnar's friends you know and
it son was like it's disgusting and he
said he's like look she's a you know
beautiful woman you know it's like look
your mom and your dad's love is famous
like they're fine like isn't gonna ruin
their relationship but yeah that was
interesting I like that yeah and the guy
that plays a Ragnar I forgot it the
actor's name was Travis Travis thimble
was using the show with the Patrick
Swayze this cop show he kind of got that
Charlie Hunnam look yeah he's good like
that he's a smaller guy but rather like
his eyes and his the way he smiled I
love how they shoot him because you
that mischievous look like he always
does it like half smirk like looking
like that gleam and I guess I have heard
his eyes are that blue they always like
focusing on his eyes but yeah he's he's
good like I said I think the cast did a
good job cast Loki Loki is crazy that's
one of the scars garnets I was in the
guards guard from True Blood that's his
brother yeah he's he's a weird character
hey he's a pyromaniac I was trying to
cause miss chill in people he's crazy
and he gets into rolos head yo you're
not being baptized
yeah I think that's another thing that I
do like about the show is kind of
showing the religious aspects of you
like the Vikings and the Christians and
and just you know how they shape each
cultures a way of living right right and
like the Vikings come to the Christians
and they're like who cares about this
stuff cross look at these these idiots
are hanging out in church we're just
beat them up you know and for them it's
so sacred yeah but I'm sure if the
Christians came and invaded the Vikings
temple they likewise are no goal worse
although yeah it does it looks it's so
different so yeah that's one of the
aspects of the show that I really like
yeah that's thing I like I think the
show's strongest when it does explore
the Viking culture the relationships
between you know like a father and a son
and the husband and wife I think it like
I said Michael Herz that's why that
comparison to Michael Bay dis baffles me
because Michael Hurst like he does care
about character like he wants to develop
his characters in the show and it's also
not super over-the-top like a Michael no
good actually like a choreographed fight
yeah but it's like Spartacus or I think
it's not crazy crazy yeah it's not like
Ragnar runs out and just like there's a
spinning like right like takes down the
guy gets beat up yes you know like Holly
talked about like the I love how they
talk about the different styles of
fighting and like these men carry axes
like you know the European the British
guys carry like you know broad swords
and stuff like that they're carrying
like axes and she'll like different
different styles of fighting they have
like their shield wall which is you
think of like Romans when you think of
that the Romans do that and they're like
just different it's just cool how they
explore all those different things about
the culture yeah all right so would it
with your overall thoughts and
grade-four
season 1 overall thoughts if you're a
game with their own span Rome Spartacus
you looking for something to fill the
time the episode is gonna premiere
Thursday this Thursday like I would say
Vikings is a show for you don't offended
to be like necessarily as good as a game
with Thrones I think it's gonna shows
gonna get better and improve I would
give it let me give it a B+ I think it's
this good show with a lot of ends I
think it has it can get better it's not
a shoulder I think it's gonna stay the
same I think it can actually get better
and I was really impressed the first
season I don't think I enjoyed it as
much as you did but I still think it's a
good show and I think has potential to
be a really good show or maybe not a
great show like Game of Thrones and some
other stuff but I think it as long as it
keeps on the same direction and gets
hopefully more complex maybe a little
more faster pace and and stuff like that
I think it can attain maybe a Spartacus
slow yeah it feels like Spartacus yeah
it's not quite as good as Spartacus but
I think it has the potential to get to
that quality right right I think I
better start spark I started a little
rough start oh yeah yeah the mostess has
a much better start yeah so I'm gonna
give it a B yeah all right guys so
legend we thought of Viking season 1 you
can post your comments below on the
website think eurocom more on our
youtube channel think you're a pro make
sure to subscribe to that also you can
chat with us on twitter dennis and i
talked about vikings you think it's a
good game with thrones filler littles
you know something to spend some time
with one see some swords and shields
clashing we're at think here oh I'm at
Griffin de and we also have a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
hero fans make sure you like that page
and share our video on Twitter and other
social media
you